thank you for having me at the session
i'm excited to talk about the tools that
we're developing at the intersection
of genomics
as well as microscopy and also how we're
applying computational tools uh to make
sense of this data for um understanding
basically the spatial localization of
genetic programs within cells and
tissues
i think
to motivate this work i want to point
out that there's been recently one
set of tools which has really advanced
revolutionized the study of molecular
mechanisms in cells and tissues
and that's uh
the set of approaches for single cell
transcriptomics
and in single cell transcriptomics you
can break down a tissue into its
constituent cells
and sample this transcriptome of each
cell
and this is powerful because it's
comprehensive it lets you look at the
cell types and states as well as the
molecular programs within those cells
and so you can get a sense of so what
are what are the molecules driving kind
of dysfunctional disease or or what are
the programs that are acting in
development
however fundamentally we have to
remember uh that um in single cell
transcriptomics you take kind of a
structured 3d tissue some biological
specimen and you dissociate it into the
slurry
of single cells and in that process you
lose kind of the structure
and the spatial context of where those
cells came from
and obviously in biology that's very
important because cells communicate to
each other uh they self-organize to form
uh kind of the structure con
and function of tissues and beyond that
you know cells and tissues are also
dynamic right they divide they migrate
and they differentiate and we also lose
kind of like not only the spatial
context but the temporal context uh when
we take these snapshots of of tissues
and so
you know we're very motivated my group
to provide uh kind of these
these contexts in single cell
measurements like how do we make these
measurements uh about the molecular
programs of cells while still
maintaining the spatial context and and
i think this is really motivated by
three main classes of organizational
problems um one is how are tissues
organized molecularly by molecularly
defined cell types
as we become
you know better and better at collecting
these single cell data sets we can find
discover hundreds of molecularly
annotated uh cell types and
we really have no idea how they're
organized within 3d tissues and then how
does the second is how does spatially
differential gene expression patterns
relate to our understanding of what a
cell type is and how cell types function
and lastly what are gene expression
changes with respect to kind of regions
of interest and such as the case of
pathology you know for a long time we've
been able to look under the microscope
and examine um features and tissues just
in in these h e stains which are just
two different differential stains of the
proteins and the nucleic acid content
and and we can use our eyes to kind of
like um or pathologists can at least use
their eyes to understand to classify
areas of dysfunction but what we'd
really like to know is how do these
like human classified areas relate to
like molecular changes
in the tissue so
to kind of
access these classes of motivational
problems uh we've developed
a technology called slide seek
which is a tool which enables
genome-wide
expression for profiling in tissues at
10 micron resolution or about the size
of single cells
in the milling tissues and this is kind
of a joint effort between my group and
evan mccoskos here at the broad and the
big picture of slide seek is it
effectively lets you do that single cell
sequencing um on targeted single cell
sequencing and at the same time it lets
you know where where your cells uh came
from
and so how do we do this uh well in
slide seek we deposit individually
barcoded polystyrene beads
each one of these beads is about 10
microns in diameter and each bead has
hundreds of millions of oligonucleotides
which have this structure where they
have a pcr handle uh which allows uh you
to amplify uh the capture captured mrna
it has a polydt uh tail which captures
uh poly a mrna a spatial bead bar code
which is kind of a clonal sequence which
is the same for all of the oligos on a
bead but different among beads
and a unique molecular identifier which
allows for counting and what we do is we
deposit these beads randomly on a
surface and then we take a microscope
and sequence the clonal bead bar codes
for each uh of these beats and so so
here's a surface with 15
of these white circles each circle is
about three millimeters in diameter with
a hundred thousand of these beads
sitting on the surface and then i i
won't exactly describe to you uh the see
this process of sequencing but uh in
effect it lets you know at the end of
the x y locations associated
with each one of these spatial bead
barcodes okay and so you can think of
each one of these uh beads as like kind
of a pixel and a camera and instead of
taking pictures of of the tissue it's
capturing parts of the transcriptome and
you're reconstructing images
of the transcriptome from these beats
and so when we um
so so when we actually perform the
experiment we can we can take these
arrays which have been produced up front
and
we can take a piece of tissue and just
actually section it on a thing called a
cryostat which is kind of like a fancy
deli slicer and you section a very thin
uh 10 micron section onto
uh these beads
the rna from that tissue gets
transferred onto the beads and then you
can put that into kind of standard uh
molecular biology approaches to
amplify
um the rna
to generate a sequencing library which
is very similar to single cell
sequencing
when you sequence the libraries um you
get data that's very much like
single cell libraries so for each
barcode on the bead
you get a vector
and along that vector you have the
counts across each gene in the
transcriptome and so across all the
barcodes you have this matrix right b
bar codes on one side and the uh genes
on the other
and now if you remember we have the
spatial location of each bead and so we
can just match them up and so now you
have an x y location to each b barcode
and now thus an x y location to each
teach read and so what does the data
look like um it actually has very
similar structure as single cell data so
we can apply similar computational tools
such as dimensional anatomy reduction
and clustering and so here we've
actually performed slight seek on the
mouse hippocampus uh and on the very uh
basically um left here we've clustered
the
the gene expression profiles in an
unsupervised way and what we've done is
we've we've colored the beads uh by
uh the cell type as clustered by as
defined by their their molecular
by the genes uh which are expressed in
each cluster and in the middle what
we've done is we've actually just
colored the beads in the array by which
cell type they belong to um and there's
actually no microscopy done but we can
reconstruct the architecture of the
tissue and where the cell types reside
and and you know here's actually uh what
what a microscope picture looks like and
you can see that you recapitulate these
layers of cells and these layers cells
uh if you know some anatomy about the
hippocamps campus uh reside in different
layers for example here's like a layer
of ca1 neurons here's the dentate gyrus
and here's oligodendrocytes which
separate the cortex from from the
hippocampus and so the so the takeaway
is that there's no microscope uh we've
actually turned the sequencer into a
microscope using these these beads as
pixels uh on the microscope
okay so um
you know just just a little bit of about
how this technology works uh it has very
high spatial resolution uh this is one
of the first questions that comes up
like what's the resolution of the
capture and we've directly compared kind
of like the features as you you see in
the sites this sort of molecular capture
approach with with microscopy of the
same features and you get that there's
there's very little diffusion happening
in this process and and so the
resolution is is really the size of the
pixel which is about 10 microns
we've we've spent a lot of work
improving the molecular sensitivity
which is like how many molecules can
each
uh
one of these pixels capture from the
tissue uh we've improved it about an
order of magnitude to about a thousand
molecules per pixel
um we think this can be improved further
and just as a sense of scale this is
similar to what you would get in the
first generation single cell sequencing
approaches and and we think there's a
couple uh factor of a couple left uh to
improve just through molecular biology
improvements
and the other thing is we really try to
uh demonstrate that it's scalable across
different tissue types and organisms uh
and we've we've demonstrated it on
across a variety of mouse organs
human human tumors and embryos and
development and the other thing is that
you can take many sections into in
serially and try to reconstruct them
into one large 3d volume so uh we have
been trying to do that and so
beyond that i think um
there's this class of spatial capture
transcriptomic problem
approaches
uh generates some very interesting like
computational problems for the analysis
of data
i've shown you how you can use
unsupervised clustering to assign cell
types to these spatial locations uh on
the array but but actually um in many
cases you'd like to be able to use
existing single cell rna seq references
where you've defined the cell types and
maybe you have higher molecular
resolution on what those cell types are
and project that into the pixels that on
the array and so so we've devised a
supervised learning approach to
decompose kind of each pixel on the
array into um single cell type cell
types as defined from a single cell
reference and
the other thing is is that each pixel
can capture rna from more than one cell
even though it's about the size of a
cell cells can land uh you know across
two pixels and so the idea is to
estimate the contributions from each
cell type to each
bead or pixel on the array using kind of
an already annotated single cell
reference uh using a
reference based probabilistic model uh
and i i won't go into detail exactly
about how the model works but the idea
uh this is really led by dylan cable
graduate student lab and and rafa uh
irizarry who's co-advising him and so um
so um we've demonstrated actually
perform detailed computational
simulations with single cell and single
nucleus data sets that demonstrates that
using this method we can classify cell
types across different sequencing
modalities for example here we use a
single cell rna seq data set
as the reference to classify single cell
sequence with single nucleus rna-seq
with the diagonal here representing
ground truth uh and um
you can see that we do quite well but
not only that we can actually now
computationally mix cell types from
these two different data sets and we can
identify mixtures of cell types
accurately i.e we can tell which two
cell types have been mixed on each pixel
and then we can decompose those pixels
those mixers into the fractional
contents of the constituent cell types
uh with quite high accuracy and so um
this is i think really exciting and gets
at the heart of what we're trying to
access with spatial transcriptomics
because uh what we really want to know
is in you know how does the gene
expression within a cell type change as
a function of its spatial context and to
be able to do that you have to
uh decompo you have to understand both
the spatial location of those cells and
be able to assign them to kind of within
like a molecular cell type um
and i think uh using rctd we're being
getting to be able to do that for
example we can condition on a given cell
type for example here on uh ca3 neurons
within the hippocampus and we can we can
discover kind of cell type specific
spatial variation uh so what what
percentage of genes what what are the
what is the variation in genes in along
this axis
of cells this is a spatial axis
uh just for example here and then these
sub regions of ca3 and importantly we
can also find gene expression uh changes
as a function of who which who your
neighbors are right like as your cell
type a like for example if you're an
astrocyte how does your gene expression
change if your neighbors are excitatory
neurons and so here are just some
examples of genes where we can
systematically discover gene expression
changes uh in your cellular neighborhood
and so i think this is going to be
extremely powerful way
uh to
like deconvolve the contributions of
cell type and cellular environment on
basically um the variation in the
transcriptome and i think this is kind
of an approach that will allow us to use
that to then discover cell cell
interactions and receptor ligands that
are actually active in between cell
types and and so this is uh something
that we're quite excited about and
really focused on working on in the lab
so just as a summary uh i i told you
about some technologies uh some
experimental technologies for for
basically spatially profiling the
transcriptome uh slight seek and and um
and this is leveraging kind of using
microscopy to generate these facially
barcoded arrays
but i think one of the
you know um
one of the most important things
as we generate lots and lots of this
data is computational algorithms
that allow us to interpret kind of this
high content
uh and high
dimensional data right because we have
gene expression across space and i i
showed you some algorithms that we
developed to assign spatial cell types
but i think there's really a lot of work
uh to be done to understand how does
gene expression vary in space within
those cell types and how do we discover
cell cell interactions and the molecular
components of those cell cell
interactions um and
the other thing that we're doing is
we're leveraging like other sorts of
genomic tools into these same sort of
measurements including
measuring kind of dna and rna separate
simultaneously in multiomics and and
kind of also uh sequencing the identity
of of receptors and immunology and
understanding how those receptors
actually uh the localization those
receptors change
within tissue
so um
thank you for your time i just want to
acknowledge the people who have done
this work including
kind of uh this is the team who does
mainly does slide seek ivan mccoska
who's uh a pi at the broad who's jointly
leading this work with me uh along with
sam and bob who uh our graduate students
who led the slight seek work uh and um
the additional members of the team here
thank you very much